وبمناسبه يوم المتبرعين في ضيافه اليوم
بنك دم متنقل
يحيى ابن محافظه الفيوم حقق رقما قياسيا
بعد تبرعه
بسبعه الاف قرب الدم منذ عام 1982 وحتى
الان ما زال تبرع مستمر
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من القاهره طبعا الملقب ببنك
الدم المتنقل يحيى عبد الغني اهلا بك يا
يحيى معنا صباح الخير
صباح النور صباح النور اهلا وسهلا اهلا
وسهلا يا يحيى طبعا جزاك الله كل خير على
تبرعك الدائم بالدم لدرجه انه سموكنا زي
ما ذكرنا بنك الدم المتنقل شو اللي خلاك
بسنه 82 تبدا بهذا المشوار اللي ما انقطع
لغايه الان بالتبرع بالدم بشكل مستمر
انا من واحد وثمانين
الو
اتفضل من 81 كان في
واحد
هيشتلوا كده
فبيلمولوا المتبرعين فرحت اتبرع
فحسيت ان انا ارتاحت
على طول فكان موجود الله يرحمه الى رحمه
الله الدكتور عبد الرحيم شحاته كان ماسك
محافظه الفيوم بلغ الاطباء والاطباء عملوا
كلثوم طبي فقال في خلايل خلايه الدم بتفرز
على طول ما بتتوقفش
بدات اتبرع بعلم اي مسؤول مسك محافظه
الفيوم منور الدكتور عبد الرحيم شحاته
الدكتور سعد نصار دكتور محمد رافت محمود
اللي هو مجدي الكبيسي
كلام مصطفى السعيد دكتور مصطفى جلال
السعيد وابو القاهره مننا كله من القاهره
فحاولت اتبرع فقلتك وعليا بنك الدم
المتنكل بالفيوم
عطيت بجميع المستشفيات
من الصعيد لابن سويف للفيوم لاي مستشفى في
القاهره لبعض ناصر لا عن شمس اي مستشفى طب
خليني اسالك قبل قبل ما نكمل حج يحيى
فصيله دمك ايه
اتفضلوا بقى وموجه او موجب يعني انت
بتتبرع للناس كلها طيب كم مره بتتبرع هو
المفترض انه الواحد بيتبرع كل 3 اشهر انت
بالنسبه ليك كل قد ايه
انا في الاسبوع بتبدا بعربه اثنين ثلاثه
في الاسبوع
اسبوع الزلزال اعتقد ست لترات وكتبها
الاستاذ عبد العظيم الباسل
عطاء المصريين مازال مستمر فيوم يتبرع
بسته انا عندي خلايا بتفرز يعني انت في
عندك حاله معينه من فضلك
حاله معينه
ايوه عندي خلايل بتفرز يعني النخاع الشوكي
بينتج خلايا الدم كثير
نعم طيب هلا في بعض الاخبار بتتحدث عن انك
دخلت موثوق موسوعه للارقام القياسيه اي
موسوعه جينيس ولا موسوعه اخرى
لا انا دخلت موسوعه جينز الارقام الكاسيه
بس لسه ما تمتش يعني هتم ان شاء الله
تقدمت ورقه بس لسه
انا والله مش هننهي اللقاء الا لما تقول
لي انت بتحس ايه بقى بس بتتبرع بالدم
قل لي نفسيتك بحس باللي ارتاح والله ترتاح
كده بحس بالارتاح وبحس
برتاح ان انا
خليني اصلا برتاح النت الناس الناس اللي
بتتبرع لها بالدم بتشكرك انقذت حياه حد
لا كتير انقاص حياه ناس كتير
بتكون على تواصل وياهم ما هو دمك اختلط
بدمه
يعني الحمد لله العالم بيدعي لي يعني هو
طب واحنا كمان ندعي لك ونقول جزاك الله كل
خير طبعا
من من كثر تبرعه على مدى عقود من الزمن
اصبح له عائله كبيره جدا في مصر وخارج مصر
شكرا جزيلا لك بنك الدم المتنقل
المشاهدينا يحيى عبد الغني من القاهره
شكرا جزيلا يا عمي
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات